foreign
it's our big five stories of 2022 we're
each taking a look at the top headlines
from the past year Jesse you go first
war in Ukraine just dominated the spring
season we covered it wall-to-wall here
on Fox News Channel you haven't seen
tanks in the European theater like that
for decades really shocked the country
shocked the world that you would see
that type of brutality again in that
part of the world the stock market took
a hit uh Energy prices were affected
Supply chains food prices it's really
scrambled the entire European energy
policy and we're still feeling the
repercussions of it and it's a cold
winter it's going to continue uh could
continue for years you never know how
it's going to play out but this was The
Story of the Year according to Jesse
Waters okay Dana well I agree on
certainly on Ukraine and the
ramifications of that are going to
continue through 2023. um as is the
story that I chose which is the one on
the border the southern border just a
couple of points here
in all of 2020
there were 458 000 encounters at the
border we are two and a half months in
to fiscal year 2023 and they're already
505 thousand that's not counting 140 000
gotaways Fox News has covered the story
every single day it is astounding to me
how every morning on America's Newsroom
we can turn to Bill malusion or Griff
Jenkins or Nate Foy whoever's down on
the border for us and you can see oh
Dana Bill 300 migrants just came across
and it's you know it's Daybreak over
here in Eagle Pass Texas or Del Rio it's
also happening in Arizona New Mexico and
California and this is also not just
bringing immigrants who are illegally
entering the country they now are
Fanning out across the country so every
state every locality is affected by it
every school every hospital and there's
no end in sight and we are about to have
a big change in this country as you see
some of the protections and reasons that
we could turn away migrants as being
blocked by courts that would be title 42
which was the public health issue so now
you are looking at having thousands of
migrants every day coming into the
country are I've never been somebody
who's like oh we're for open borders to
me it feels like the border is totally
open and I I'm just shocked that you
have a commander-in-chief who has turned
a blind eye to it and just think about
this anybody who traveled over the
holidays or if you have plans in the
future you're going to go through TSA
you're going to have to take off your
belt take off your shoes put your stuff
through security and why do we do that
to keep us all safe and we this is an
agreement we have all made and we might
think it's really annoying but we all do
it there were 98 people caught last year
that were on the terrorist watch list
those are the ones that we caught at the
border with a million gotaways all said
how many else how many others are there
and we're not doing enough to protect
this country not only from all the
problems that it could lead to
in regards to your social structure but
also I think the worry is on from a
national security perspective and as
Jesse pointed out earlier in the month
we have a situation with a narco State
on our Southern border this is a huge
story and what's shocking is that
there's not more reporters willing to
cover it you know what it is a huge
story Dana and the craziest part of it
is that we have basically lost our
sovereignty as a nation we are no longer
a Sovereign Nation we are nothing more
than a global landing spot for anyone
who wants to come here and you know just
last week I was listening and there was
something like in one week people from
96 different countries arrived in the in
you know through the border illegally
and uh but but Tyrus what's your take on
the board on what day is talking about
well the Border I think has also been
I'm using the term it's like a Gateway
for what we're seeing a ripple done
effect across the country because it
leads to so many other things now I'm
not saying that everyone who crosses the
border the Danish point is a criminal or
a terrorist but it does lead because
that border also we have all the
fentanyl coming in so we're creating
more problems for our residents it's in
the neighborhoods that are directly next
to the Border are overwhelmed the cities
and towns are overwhelmed with no help
in sight Jessica the sad part about it
is now that so many people are coming
through with a you know with title 42
basically being eliminated we're hearing
about people who are sleeping on the
streets where they're not enough beds
it's cold in Texas right now right and I
mean the humanitarian way to handle it
would be to at least create some kind of
safety net for them well that's what
happened before the numbers skyrocketed
to these levels there was this push to
build enough facilities and then we
found out that 1500 beds aren't enough
because you're getting 3 000 people in
item what are you to do about that and
you used exactly the right word
humanitarian so whatever kind of Crisis
you want to have if you want to have a
national security crisis that's fine if
that's how Republicans want to talk
about it but Democrats if you want to
talk about it from the human level
that's just as important as what's going
on in the National Security side because
there are people who are becoming
homeless there are people who are being
raped coming across here people who are
selling their children there are people
just flat out dying making this very
very dangerous Journey so until then
Jesse why is the administration not
addressing the issues that Jessica's
talking about well it's part strategy
part incompetence they wanted to do the
exact opposite of what Trump did and
they want cheap labor for their donors
and they also want new voters and they
want people to come here and have babies
that's what AOC and Schumer said all
part of a plan so they're either
executing the plan or they don't know
what they're doing either way it's not
good it isn't anyway
on to my story of the year my story of
the year has to do with Elon Musk
exposing Twitter I think this is the
biggest story of the year because for
centuries As Americans uh in fact this
country was founded on the concept of
free speech the First Amendment the
ability to say what you want and that
first amendment doesn't just address you
and I speaking IT addresses the power of
the press and the ability of the press
to not suffer from prior uh constraints
and what we had in America and what we
saw as a result of Elon Musk exposing
what was going on at Twitter was that
there was prior restraint there was
suppression of free speech there was
suppression not only of Free Speech but
suppression in One Direction so that
there would be an election impacted in
one particular way and not both ways and
I think that this chilling censorship
indicates to me the end of a democracy
just as with the Border we are now no
longer a Sovereign Nation but a
globalist landing spot with Benefits we
now have a a press that is not being
that is not holding up its part of the
deal as the fourth estate that all of us
as Americans relied on to kind of check
what government was doing to be that
fourth estate it's not happening anymore
and when the head of Twitter was called
before Congress he lied he lied under
oath now he can say right no oh I didn't
know what was going on at my own company
hogwash you knew Jack Dorsey why you
were called before Congress you knew the
issue had to do with Hunter Biden and
you knew that there was you know 51
officials intelligence officials who
said it looked like Intel uh like
Russian disinformation so you knew there
was an issue there that you had to
address before you went to Congress but
no you put your hand down you swore to
tell the truth and you lied and so the
search results being manipulated that
affected a federal election the end of
the First Amendment to me is one of the
biggest stories not only of 2022 but of
the century so far what say you Jesse I
agree and in 10 years we may even see
this being bigger because things are
still coming out and Elon confessed he
said I'm here to save democracy I'm here
to save free speech and the fact that he
plowed what 44 billion into this thing
and then just kind of wrestled it away
from the grip of the FBI the CIA the
Democratic National Committee shows you
how fast we were veering towards not the
Republic that we know and love and
thank you to Elon Musk for doing that
everybody owes this guy a big debt of
gratitude yep I couldn't agree more Dana
what's your take on well I think that we
were in this middle if you look back in
history at New Year's is a good time to
do that and you think back not only to
just the past year but just as in the
scope of things to come I think when the
history books are written people will
look back at this period and say social
media had been given this free reign for
a while because nobody knew what it was
going to be like and then it turns out
to be something that we realize oh gosh
that's not very good in fact it's
actually destroying well leading to
destruction of some parts of our
democracy and so Elon Musk takes a pin
and bursts the balloon and now we can
all have a chance to regroup and I think
in the next year you might see some
attempts by Congress to do something
about it however Congress is always
behind the times when it comes to
technology and the private sector will
just have creative destruction and
create something new and that's
something that Elon Musk is doing all
right tyro's your reaction woke
martyrdom that's what it's that's what
they're going to say it was it was it
wasn't about Hunter Biden it was always
one one thing the mission was simple you
have to stop president Trump for
whatever reason all the things that he
was going to drain the swamp he did not
realize how deep the swamp was and how
many monsters were in it and they came
out and their whole thing no matter how
they look at yes we use the FBI yes we
but we did it our greater good was we
had to stop president Trump and we saw
the entire time and it worked so you
will not see any oh I'm sorry you will
not see any of that and these they
weren't necessarily Democrats these are
just this woke group that has decided
what the country needs because they
virtue signal they know what's best even
though it wasn't for the best and we're
seeing the results of that so
um it it will be always be called the
woke martyrdom but when you look back at
this at 10 years president Trump I think
the light is going to be very different
on him based off all the evidence we're
starting to see all right Jessica your
big story for 2022. so my big story was
the red wave that wasn't or maybe Joe
Biden isn't that
how I call it so I think there are three
main takeaways from the midterm results
and and we all know that we're just
constantly in campaign mode and what did
we get off you know a few days before we
started going into what's going to
happen in 2024 but there were some
pretty big lessons from it so the first
sorry reference maybe Joe Biden isn't
that bad maybe and Jesse I thought one
of the points you made a couple months
ago was really Salient which is people
just don't hate him the way that they
hate others you do try and sometimes you
succeed
um no but it's a really important point
that he doesn't raise this level of ire
or animosity as a Hillary or Barack
Obama and we can talk about why that may
be I think most people understand
certainly why I think that is so Joe
Biden had the most successful midterm
since the 1930s it's a really big deal
so there's a house majority for the
Republicans very slight Kevin McCarthy
not being able to Corral the caucus as
he expected
um so that's a really interesting aspect
of it the two other things that I think
are important out of the midterm results
first of all the importance of the issue
of abortion that the Dobb's ruling may
not have been the gift for Republicans
that they thought that it was and I
understand that for a lot of uh pro-life
activists that this is the long game
right that it's not about winning an
election today or in two years four
years whatever it is it's about
protecting life
um and the way that they see it but
people showed up Democrats a lot of
Republicans a lot of moderates and said
that what's going on in very
conservative States is unacceptable
you'll see a lot more of these
referendums like in Kansas and Kentucky
Michigan and you had Jim Messina on
America's Newsroom uh right after where
he said yeah we're gonna run the table
on this and make sure that everyone
votes on it the third Point that's
important Donald Trump's impact on the
midterms was terrible just like it was
in 2020 lost the Senate again as a
result of hand-picked candidates that he
thought were great and that ended up
being really terrible and I know that
he's declared to run for president but
right now it looks like a campaign and
name only and he's losing a lot of
salience in the party happy New Year
yeah oh I'm sorry the Border is open we
have no free speech yeah Democrats one
what's your big story
crime and homelessness and I think they
go hand in hand we've seen more videos
this year of just Americans just being
awful to each other and little or no
consequences the no cash bail has hurt a
lot of families destroyed businesses and
again this is where I talked about the
Border fentanyl coming in Fentanyl and
meth are now the two leading causes of
homelessness in this country those
numbers have like almost doubled
probably by the time in a few months
from now they'll triple because people
and no there's no help there's no media
attention to it we don't see it China
manufactures it they send it to they
send it to Mexico to be made and then it
comes to America and kills our kids and
then ones who aren't being killed by it
they end up so strung out and we see the
zombies walking the streets and everyone
doesn't do it it's not until
Unfortunately they die that somebody
cares enough to talk about no one's
making the effort the media is not
interested in it I am one of the things
that was very proud about being a Fox
News contributors that we did talk about
it we kept bringing it up and it needs
to be and it's very simple you have to
cut the snake's head off and where do
you do that one you pick up the phone
and you tell Chinese stop sending that
stuff two
I know Gutfeld likes to bomb things I
like to Target things you can drop
little
in Spanish waivers all over these little
factories where they make this stuff and
let them know that a missile's coming
your way on this day you can blow up
these spot these are terrorists if these
were in Iraq or these were in
Afghanistan they were making these
plants and sending it over here we would
do something about it so something needs
to be done but I'm glad at least they're
getting a voice here because this story
should have been the top story because
who were the victims are American
citizens and our kids and there's just
not enough voices for them yeah great
great segment hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else